and just after midnight Friday the
threat of a trade war between the US and
China moved from rhetoric to reality the
Trump administration imposed tariffs on
thirty four billion dollars worth of
Chinese goods China immediately
retaliated with duties on the same value
of American products here to tell us
where this could lead and how it may
affect consumers and businesses is
Derrick Thompson senior editor at the
Atlantic Derrick welcome thanks good to
be here what's the endgame for the Trump
administration here do you think that's
a great question I actually don't know I
think that there are two possibilities
if I had to read into his mind on the
one hand there's the economic reason and
on the other hand there's the political
reason that he's doing this the economic
reason is that it is reasonable to have
gripes with what China is doing with
regard to its trade policy what they're
essentially doing is forcing Western
tech companies to hand over the
proprietary data as a precondition for
entering the market that's a no-no they
shouldn't do that on the other hand
there's the political reason and I think
Trump still sees himself as the kind of
talisman of white working-class America
and he's standing up against the world
not just China but also Canada and the
EU slapping tariffs on steel and
aluminum for them essentially saying
it's us against the world I'm going to
stand and fight for you even when I
don't specifically tell you what it is
that I'm fighting for but how long is
that likely to work out for the
president because China seems pledged to
hang in on this for the long term the US
economy is strong so it'll take time for
it to pinch but this could hit Trump
supporters in the Midwest soybean
producers and the like I think it's
exactly right it's a soybean producers
Harley Davidson has said that they're
gonna move some of their factories
overseas there's talks that factories
might not get investment from banks
internationally when we think about a
trade war I think it's really useful to
think of it as a tax war right it's a
tax skirmish and the tax kermis that's
going on right now between the US and
China is a little bit like two kids who
sort of go underwater to test who can
hold their breath along yes right
because what you're really doing in a
trade war is punishing yourself you were
taxing your own companies your own
consumers and essentially saying how
long can we hold out until my opponent
changes the strategy but here's the
problem with going into a trade war with
China China can hold its breath longer
than anybody
right this is a socialist market-based
economy with unelected leaders who don't
have midterms in five months who can
basically subsidize their industries ad
infinitum and under are under no
pressure to change their strategy in the
short term so we've picked the wrong kid
to go into a you know breath-holding
contest against knowledge and China
certainly is ratcheting up its rhetoric
saying that the Trump administration is
a gang of hoodlums talk to us Derek a
little bit about how these tariffs can
potentially backfire
you mentioned harley-davidson China of
course you know if it were to put
tariffs on tech companies you know that
could really hurt you know American
companies but also a lot of companies
produce their products like iPhones in
China so it's also interconnected
explain that to us about so you know
there have been nine own goals in the
World Cup so far this summer that's the
highest in tournament history this is
the tenth own bowl of the Sun even the
US didn't enter the tournament we still
valuators have an own goal
um 87 percent of the computer companies
in China that are subject to this tariff
are non Chinese and a lot of them are
American of the 30 districts that are
most affected by the soybean tariffs
that China is now implemented on the US
25 of them voted for Donald Trump this
is a self-inflicted wound we are taxing
ourselves in order to punish China for a
completely unrelated tech problem we
should be working with the international
community building alliances not taxing
our neighbors and trashing NATO well
we'll see how far it all goes because
it's probably gonna escalate from here
but there are Tufts and thanks very much
for being with us this morning thank you